This video is sponsored by Squarespace.
When American astronaut Scott Kelly spent
a year at the International Space Station
in 2015 and 2016, his heart shrank by 25%
in mass according to a study published this year.
Without the pull of gravity, the heart doesn’t
have to pump as hard.
Studies like these are being done as space
opens up to more people who will journey
deeper into the solar system.
Space travel is hard on the body.
For every month of flight, you lose about
1.5% of bone density according to NASA.
Bones don’t have to support the body against
gravity.
The farther you are from Earth, the weaker
the gravitational force.
For longer trips - say, going to Mars - which
takes about six months each way - that would
mean losing roughly 10% of your total bone
density.
Your weaker bones would be more prone to fractures.
After spending half a year in space, recovery
could take 3 to 4 years.
The best way to build up bone mass is to do
weight-bearing exercises - in which your bones
support your weight.
Like tennis, skip rope, or jogging.
Running on a treadmill at the ISS is a little
different as astronauts have to strap themselves in.
Despite the effort, you’ll likely only be
able to slow down the rate of bone loss - not
prevent it altogether.
Artificial gravity could help.
A proposed private space hotel called Voyager
is designed to spin slowly to mimic the effects
of a gravitational force.
Besides losing bone density, muscles can weaken
from lack of use and deteriorate.
Research from previous missions shows astronauts
lose up to 20% of muscle mass on flights lasting
less than two weeks.
Many astronauts also report back pain, as
weakened muscles provide less support for
the spine.
In order to combat muscle loss, a machine
called an ARED imitates weight lifting to
work all the major muscle groups and decrease
the recovery time later.
Though again, it doesn’t get better right
away once astronauts return to Earth.
They’re at a much higher risk of a herniated
disc.
The lack of gravity is also problematic for
the cardiovascular system since there’s
nothing to pull blood to the lower part of
the body.
Instead, it goes to the chest and head, causing
astronauts to have puffy faces and bulging
blood vessels in their necks.
Canadian researchers have discovered that
this chronic increase in blood pressure to
the head and neck can result in stiffer arteries
in which a six-month mission is similar to
ageing 10 to 20 years on Earth.
NASA requires aspiring astronauts to have
a blood pressure reading of no more than 140/90
measured in a sitting position.
They’ll also have to pass physical tests
in a swimming pool - the best place to simulate
the feeling of weightlessness in space.
Candidates have to swim three laps of a 25-meter
pool non-stop which doesn’t sound that difficult.
But then they have to repeat it.
This time wearing a blue flight suit and
tennis shoes and then tread water for 10 minutes.
However, being physically fit won’t protect
against the very serious threat of radiation.
We’re protected from some of the most dangerous
rays and particles because of Earth’s magnetic field.
But beyond low Earth orbit is a world teeming
with radiation which is measured using Milli-Sievert (mSv).
1 mSv is the equivalent of about three chest
x-rays.
A six-month trip to the ISS or the moon exposes
astronauts to doses ranging from 50 to 2,000
mSvs - that would be like having 150 to 6,000
chest x-rays.
And it’s ionizing radiation - it can destroy
cells and damage DNA, increasing the risk
of cancer and degenerative diseases.
Protecting against radiation on the moon or
Mars means building habitats with reliable shielding.
But in transit, you’re only protected by
what’s around you.
A strategy tested by NASA’s space radiation
specialists involves crew members barricading
themselves with stowage bags.
Other techniques being developed include wearable
vests that add another layer of mass and electrically
charged surfaces that can deflect these dangerous
particles.
Exposure to radiation experienced by Scott
Kelly is believed to have activated certain
genes known to encode proteins that help fix
damaged DNA.
Researchers gleaned all of this information
by comparing Scott to his identical twin Mark,
also an astronaut, who remained on Earth as
the control subject.
The stresses of being in orbit appear to have
altered Scott’s immune system, worsened
his eyesight, and, oddly, lengthened the caps
at the ends of his DNA strands called telomeres.
These protect chromosomes - kind of like how
plastic handles protect jump ropes.
Usually, they shorten as we age.
The strange lengthening disappeared a few
days after he returned to Earth.
However, seven per cent of his gene expression still remained
altered six months later.
More research is now being done to study the
lasting impact of space travel on our bodies.
Not to mention there are behavioral effects
of being restricted to a spacecraft for a
long period of time.
To make astronauts feel a little less isolated,
they got internet access on the ISS a decade ago.
Being able to go online and access websites
is a crucial way of communicating these days,
which brings me to the sponsor of this video,
Squarespace.
Whether you want to grow your business, start
a blog, or showcase your work, you can easily
create a site on Squarespace without any experience in website building.
That’s what I did. I used Squarespace to
create my website for Newsthink.
You can try building a site for free by heading
to squarespace.com/newsthink.
The link is in my description.
And when you’re ready to launch, be sure
to use my promo code: NEWSTHINK to save 10%
off your first purchase of a website or a
domain.
For Newsthink, I’m Cindy Pom.